everyone
from i guess all over the world in all
sorts of different time zones um my name
is jimmy bogards
and uh you can find me on twitter at
jboguard
uh this presentation on as well the all
the code and examples are on my github
at github.comguard and i blog a lot
about this topic and a bunch of other
stuff my blog at jimmybogar.com a little
bit about myself
um i'm a independent consultant also the
acting
chief architect headspring and
independent consulting agency out of
austin texas
i do a lot of open source stuff um and i
think they give me the mvp award for it
now but they don't really say so
yay i guess and yeah this is uh
this is a fun topic for me because i've
been having to deal with this problem
for i guess almost 15 years now uh the
problem
of distributed tracing and for as long
as i've had to deal with distributed
systems
i've i've wanted to know like what the
heck is actually going on behind the
scenes
and over my career i've had to build
distributed tracing infrastructure from
scratch
at least twice and while it is like a
fun project
and uh you know it's it's infrastructure
so you know you're your own product
owner you get to make up all your own
features and it's fun to do
um like my clients don't care about that
they just want it to work uh
and so sometimes i don't have the time
or money to be able to
implement my own distributed tracing um
but in the last couple years two or
three years
uh distributed tracy has now become much
much easier to
implement and put in place in your
applications so
uh in this hour i want to show what i've
been doing in the past year or so with
the clients
uh putting in distributed tracing and
very complex microservices kind of
environment because you know
microservices yay so uh for
a good part of my career um i was just
dealing with like
single single process single application
um kinds of systems uh those could get
pretty complex right they're desktop or
web applications
uh but the entire application is
basically in one single process
now uh what that means though is that if
something were to go wrong
in this process an exception gets thrown
to something like that
then you get this nice thing this is a
this is a stack trace
and the strike trace tells me exactly
where in my code
the exception occurred but not just that
location also shows a stack
of all the calls leading up to wherever
i found that exception
so for a lot of my career like this is
all i really needed right like something
goes wrong in my application
i see the exception i can i can see
exactly what methods were called
if i'm debugging as well then i can go
see like well it was past the
these arguments over here and these
arguments over here and trace that all
the way back up to the entry point of
the application
um but this works for like everything
inside a single process
it looks fantastic right i just got the
entire trace
and stack is in memory so i'm able to
walk back up the
stack and figure out exactly how you got
there uh but these days my applications
i deal with
aren't so simple uh they're more
complicated they're
they're multiple applications talking to
each other
using various kinds of protocols so in
my application
if the user hits some api from the front
end
but the exception is way over here in
the back end
well the exception stack trace is in
that application
way down in the lower right hand corner
and the
top model part of the application in the
api i don't necessarily see any of that
information
i just see you know some kind of api
exception that occurred
but otherwise the stack trace ends in
the api
and doesn't peek through into the other
downstream systems
so me as a developer or sre
trying to figure out okay i got this
exception in my logs how did this happen
and
what are the sequence of calls that led
up to this specific exception happening
um i don't have a lot of options
available for me for
a lot of my career what i would do is
just spit out log files and so if i
wanted to figure out
what went wrong in that log file i would
look for that application's logs and
then
try to correlate back to the logs from
the other servers and correlate logs
back to the other service
and maybe i can enrich those logs with
things like contextual identifiers like
well is this user id
under this session identifier but still
it's like all these different logs from
all these different places that are very
difficult to correlate together
uh and even if you dump them all in one
location it's just a
big haystack that you're trying to piece
together
how the needle fell into it to be able
to diagnose what the heck was going
wrong
so uh in one of my first really big
distributed systems i worked with
we thought we had a great idea which is
okay
what i'd like to do is be able to
correlate some of these calls together
and if i if if time isn't good enough
like the
the kind of time stamp from one to
another that's not that's not accurate
enough we need something a little bit
better
so what i really need to know is when
system a is making a call to system
b that in that call that i'm making i
need to pass some kind of correlation
information
so that in system b it's able to look at
that incoming information to say aha
in my log files i'm not just going to
put my identifiers i'm also going to
include
the upstream um services identifiers as
well
and so that's really what distributed
tracing is intended to solve
uh it's able to piece together or you
know put humpty
dumpty back together again by including
context correlation identifiers
through every single communication
between different services
and then when those individual services
need to report out
information about what's going on they
don't just include information about
that service but they also pull in
the contextual identifier that they've
received from their upstream service
and with this kind of scheme in place
then system a calling system b will
include a context identifier
and insist to be including that context
amplifier in their logs
then something that's collecting all of
these logs
can start to put all these different
identifiers together in order to present
basically like a linked list or uh
or graph a directed acyclic draft of all
these calls being made to all these
different services it's kind of like a
like a get source control history view
that you want to see
all these different different calls
linked together
so this is you know fun to build i guess
because you have to
figure out you know what should the
headers be of all this piece of
information what do the identifiers look
like
and so some very large companies that
build these kinds of systems
said okay right um you know this is
really nothing to do with a core
business so why don't we do the
why don't we do the altruistic thing and
open source it uh instead of selling it
or whatever
so some companies did that uh one good
example of that is zipkin
zipskin is a very popular distributed
tracing utility it's free you can run it
in your own box
it doesn't require a lot of resources to
get up and running and what they've done
is basically two things one is
provide a standard for what those
identifiers look
like as it goes from place to place to
place
and they include a couple pieces of
information one is just the identifier
of this one individual
operation that's known as a span id
inside zipkin
another thing which i didn't show here
is way to link all those different calls
together some kind of
global identifier for all those
different sub operations and components
and that was known as a trace id so with
a trace id and a stand id
you get all the logs together of one
specific global operation
and then the span ideas give you the
linking of how call a
is correlated with call b so zipkin
includes this scheme of like headers
flowing through your system
and so you still have to have like
something needs to put those headers in
as i make calls from place to place
uh so you still have to do that uh and
the other place thing you need is
like okay so i i have the span id and
i've got the parent span id
what do i do to be able to get that
information
so these spans need to be reported to
something
so what do i report those spans to
um so what i could do is uh as part of
my zipkin application what they have is
an api that gets called so every time
uh you have a a a span or operation
completed
then what i can do is then call that api
to say hey i've got some spam
information
and so zipkin provides a server to
receive that those fans
and the last piece of the puzzle is well
you gotta you gotta see this stuff
uh and so zigban also provides a user
interface to be able to show
and search for individual traces and so
distributed tracing is one of the
three pillars of observability the other
two being logs and metrics you can't
just have logs you can't just have
metrics
you need all three to have that kind of
complete picture so distributed tracing
for me
really completes the other two pictures
of well how the heck did this thing
happen
to be able to get to this point so not
necessarily even exceptions
uh if something there's some customer
journey that happened how did those
different pieces get pulled together
so uh zipkin came up with their their
application
became super popular and then other
companies started
to adopt this individual standard but it
wasn't just that standard there were
several other standards as well so other
tracing utilities had their own
identifiers like
microsoft application insights that
their their own identifiers and
pretty much any distributed chasing
visual visualizer on the market
had their own like custom spin on this
and
as the kcd comic goes you know what
happens when you have
in standards uh in different
implementations you make another
standard
which is now n plus one implementations
and so that's what uh some folks from a
lot of different companies did
to get together and say let's let's
build one single standard for all these
different ways
of doing these kinds of uh tracing
identifiers flowing through the system
and so that's what the w3c uh
did that uh you know does a lot of
different um
a lot of different uh standardization
efforts
they said let's get together with some
folks from uh tracing tools and
and uh hosting providers and other
distributed tracing tools uh
visualizers as well and collectors and
and application service providers too
and said let's
get together and decide on a good
standard for how do we show this
how do we trace this information through
and so that's what the w3c
trace context uh standard is all about
now this was just
finalized earlier this year like
february it was finally taken out of
draft mode and into
like ready to go mode for for that
standard
and it describes a way of of uh
formulating the identifiers how to
format them and then ways
and behaviors of how different systems
should behave when they receive this
tracing information
now the next piece of the puzzle was
microsoft in the dot-net core world so
this is distributed tracing
made easy with net core well dot net
core and
net has had diagnostics for a very long
time
and that api uh
was really customized uh for a lot of
the microsoft environment so it didn't
really jive with
this overall standardization support so
as part of the w3c
trace context effort microsoft
shifted their development of their
diagnostics apis
to now support these kinds of standards
out of the box
so that's the other part i'll be showing
today is the the apis
inside of net core to support
these kinds of standard tracing supports
so the identifiers of the flow through
the system uh this is coming from the
activity api
and then the ids that are transported
on the wire across services are done
through it through a special
header called the trace parent header so
you can actually inspect your traffic
today and you'll probably see that for
a lot of your traffic because it's
starting to be turned on by default
and in a lot of systems these days
now this w3c standard
was really described for http traffic so
if i have services that use
apis web apis to talk to each other
that's what that was all about
they also had some extensions for grpc
to have some more compact identifier
support so where grpc like the
size and the wire really matters they
shrunk down those identifiers for those
kinds of indications over the wire but
the systems i work with
don't just deal with grpc and http they
deal with a lot of
messaging as well and so with messaging
it's still
a kind of communication going over the
network it just happens to be durable
and written down
as opposed to http which is more of a
stateless
uh protocol so with that we have to
figure out
you know well look what do we need to do
for those kinds of systems when i have
an api calling a service but then that
uses rabbitmq
then how do i extend my system to be
able to
include the right context information on
communications going out the door
and when i receive communications how do
i ensure that it correctly sets
the current operation identifiers so
that if any of
any other calls making out the door that
the context is correctly
flowed through so i'll be looking at
that today as well
now the w3c trace context standard is
really about that
identifier on the wire and how to deal
with it whenever you receive it
but it doesn't say anything about what
to do with that information
so if i just had that trace information
i guess i could still log it out to disk
but that's boring and really difficult
to deal with because now i just have all
these identifiers and log files that i
have to again humpty dumpty back
together again myself
not the most fun thing in the world to
do so
that last part is a new emerging
standard to be able to
try to standardize on the collection of
that information
and i really noticed the problem when i
was trying to put in distributed chasing
with the reason
that with recent clients and they didn't
know yet
what tracing tool to use in order to
visualize
their traces so we looked first at
zipkin
zipkin has a lot of extensions for net
core based applications and a ton of
other different platforms as well
but if i am a product company that
wanted to build
infrastructure plug-ins for tracing
tools then i have to build one for
zipkin
but there's like a dozen of these on the
market these distributed tracing tools
so when the next one comes along
around like jager then i would have to
develop these kind of api calls into
this different tracing tool as well
and so a new effort came into play of
not just trying to standardize
on the communication between services
for these tracing calls
but also recording of the traces as well
because just communicating the
information between services is just one
little like that's just kind of table
stakes to be able to even do
distributed tracing but then to report
on it
i don't have to support all these
different kind of tracing models
so that's where the open telemetry
project comes into play
so in addition to standardizing and the
communication open telemetry strives to
standardize on the reporting
of logs metrics and traces
now for a lot of platforms they don't
have any kind of
uh clear standard on how to do these
sort of things but some do
like java java's ecosystem has a
very well standardized way of dealing
with logs they don't necessarily have a
great way of dealing with traces so open
telemetry step says and says okay
we will define the uh the the apis
for what this collection should look
like and these object models should look
like
and then all these different collecting
and reporting utilities just need to go
off that common model in order for them
to be able to be plugged in
and work so with these
pieces in place open telemetry really
pushing towards the standardized api
and the standards between the different
communications and services
that makes it really easy for me as an
application developer to turn on
distributed tracing and be able to
visualize it easy without having a lot
of vendor lock-in to say
well we picked zipkins so that's you
know that's what we got to do now
because
you know so architect somewhere decided
that was the way to go
now i will say that one thing that is
little different in dot in the dotnet
world than
other platforms is net already had
an api in place for reporting operations
and traces and that's that activity api
so
the folks from microsoft and the focus
from for an open telemetry really wanted
to have
the best end user experience and so what
the team decided to do is
instead of making this entirely new api
to the side
that would require them to throw away
everything they've done so far with
uh with any kind of tracing whatsoever
instead of what they've done is
move the existing activity api to
support the open telemetry model
and the downside is the names don't
exactly match so it's called an activity
versus a span
uh they can't really do anything about
that but that also meant that it was a
much
faster uh way for them to get there
without having to go through and just
kind of replace all this existing code
that has worked for years and years and
years
and be very difficult to upgrade in
place so
uh we'll be doing in a demo in a couple
minutes here
we'll be showing the activity api for
w3c trace context propagation
we'll also be looking at how to include
additional like user
or machine specific information to
ensure that information finally shows up
on
the actual tracing information at the
end
i'll be looking at the open telemetry
for activity adapter
that is the piece from open telemetry
that plugs into what the activity looks
like
and then finally we'll look at jager and
zippin zipkin
as our open telemetry exporters all in
uh
net core 3.1 i wasn't quite brave enough
to go to dinette 5
rc2 which released like i don't know
three hours ago um
not quite that brave but i will be
showing what you will need to change
when you move from.net core 31 to net 5
when it drops next month
in order to get this to all continue to
work so
first up let's just look at some basics
of the activity api
and one of the reasons why i think this
is important the underlying activity api
is if you want to enrich your
information that
shows up in your traces you're going to
need to know how to deal with activities
so let me swap over to the old visual
studio
not the rc this is just a stock visual
and let's just see if we can make this
application break
so uh if i were to have a method here
public
boy static stack
i do something
and this through an exception
load up
now if i call do something from right
here
then of course i though an exception i
would get a stack trace and it would
tell me exactly where that needs
exactly where that exception occurred
now let's suppose that this
do something method was not in my code
that was in someone else's code and then
i consumed that code from inside my
application
and if something went wrong i wanted
some more insight into what was going on
there
well what typically would happen is you
would in that
by in that consuming application that
consuming code
you would have logging statements inside
of there and microsoft has created the i
logger of i
logger of t
interface to provide a standard way of
doing logging inside of systems
however if this do something method
is not in this application but is
somewhere else completely then
how do i make sure that whatever i'm
doing here
i can still see what's going on over
there
and that's really where the activity api
comes into play
so the first thing we do is we'll say
var activity equals new activity
and we need to give the activity an
operation name
now this sometimes is the method name
sometimes it's just the
the name of the logical operation that's
happening like running application
and before this interesting operation
happens
then we need to start our activity so we
call
activity.start
we do whatever interesting operation
we're going to do
and then the last thing we do is stop
the activity
not stop okay
when my activity is stopped we do get
interesting information as part of it
we get the duration as a time stamp so
if we're trying to get some metrics
about what our system is doing
that's kind of like a a stopwatch in
order to say
this operation took this long to do
so what about in this do something
method i'm going to get rid of this
exception because that'll look ugly
so i'll just do console.writeline
do something
now imagine this line of code is
somewhere else completely
and i need to provide some contextual
information
to this method so that it knows where
it's been called from the outside world
now inside this do something method we
want to do the exact same thing we did
before
let's say var activity equals new
activity
do something
and we do the same thing activity let's
start
and
yep that stop
okay i'm gonna put some breakpoints in
here
just to see what we see so i will put a
breakpoint
right here when we call do something and
then we call
activity.stop and then we'll put another
break point
right here and right here okay
so uh as we go through
it will instance the activity start it
call the other method
and then the other method will call that
activity.start as well
so we'll say activity.start and then if
i look at the activity information we'll
notice that the activity
has been given now an id an id looks
gobbledygoop right it's like a
pipe character with some uh hexadecimal
alphanumeric junk uh it's probably some
matrix code there i have no idea
but it's calling inside of there i'll go
ahead and continue
now that this activity that's not been
started yet if i look at it we'll notice
that
it has no id as part of it just has the
name
now if i hit f5 after we start let's go
take a look
okay it's got an id well let's scroll
down a little bit
i also notice that it has a parent id
and that parent id is the id of the
previous activity that you had in the
other method
it even has a reference to the parent
activity so i can go activity.parent
dot id but
how did it do that i didn't pass the
activity through
like i didn't i didn't give it the
activity just like i said activity.start
and it just
kind of magically knew that there was an
activity around
to connect it to this activity that got
started
so this is one of the key things that uh
these tracing tools have to do is
i need to be able to in my code somehow
flow context between different
operations
so that when i report on them i'm able
to say like this is my parent operation
to be able to link those things together
so depending on my platform it achieves
it in different ways
and the way that this platform does it
uh
net core is with a special
very special property on the activity
class called
activity.current
so on the activity
type there's an activity that current
property that's a nullable property so
there may not be an activity
and what that is is an async local
static
property or static field underneath the
covers
um that's able to be shared across any
uh thread of code that's sharing the
same async context
so in an asp.net core application that
shares the common
um and common async context that
activity.current will continuously
updated whatever async local context i'm
working with
now some applications and systems they
don't have that available to it
so instead of trying to rely on that
thing they'll just stuff it in some
collecting variable parameter that goes
through the infrastructure
but uh anytime i call activity.start it
will update
that current with the new currents and
then connect the parent to whatever that
current is
i do this because i was so curious i
looked in the code like what how's this
magic working
but that's just all it's doing you know
i have a new activity called start and
set the parent
equal to the current activity and then
set the new current
to the new activity and i'm good to go
now uh those ids though you notice were
not the greatest looking they were
pretty ugly and so what we the next
thing we want to do is
uh use this new w3c standard
for our identifiers and so to do that
it's a little bit wonky in dinette core
3 0 and 3 1
but it works and the way we do that is
at the very beginning we say activity
dot
default id format equals and have a
choice
hierarchical unknown or w3c the other
two we don't want
w3c is the one that we do want so that's
the w3c
trace context format and something we
also tend to do in our
in our systems uh activity
that force default id format just to
make sure that if someone
fiddled with this we would get the one
that we just set so now let me run this
again and see how our ids
look different
and when we see them we'll see some
additional information that we didn't
see before
in my activity we'll see that the format
of the id
is a lot bigger like zero zero dash
gobbledygook dash more gobbledygook dash
another couple numbers at the end so
this format is actually
you know defined in the w3c trace
context standard
and inside of that whole id we have a
few things going on
we have the id of the operation or the
span so the thing that's happening right
now
we also have the id of the entire trace
that's the second part we see there the
4bd whatever
so that is common across all operations
that are connected with this initial
activity that started
and then i can also have operation
individual operation numbers and so
that's what those numbers are at the end
which
typically don't get used in my systems
but are possible they're part of the
standard
so in the next application activity i
start what we'll notice
is that some of the numbers are much
different so
at the end here the ed4c that's very
different than 4db
but the first part which is the trace
identifier is going to be exactly the
same
and this is so that collectors of this
information can quickly index individual
traces
for all this real reporting of spans
coming in over the wire
okay so another way of
providing activity operation information
inside by writing application
well the next thing we need to do is be
able to propagate that information
out the door so that is when i make a an
api call
on you know net core application i want
to make sure that that trace identifier
actually flows out
to the other side and then on the
consumer side when i receive that api
call if that
incoming api call has that header in
there i want to make sure that i set
that as my new activity parent id and
you can do that i can say
activity dot parent id equals
hello in dc sydney
oh you could do that um probably want to
use an actual standardized format for
that
but you can certainly do that oh yes i
just say
set parent id but you get the idea i can
set the parent id to anything i want
so in my in infrastructure inside
asp.net core they do exactly
this for incoming incoming asp.net core
calls they'll check the header
if the header exists for that w3c
standard they will
then they will set the parent id of this
current activity
for this asp.net request and when they
make calls out the door using http
client they'll do the exact same thing
in reverse they will set the trace
context identifier on the header
as it goes out the door so
let's go back uh that was just the
activity basics um
that's useful for when we want to have
our own uh operations and speeds that we
want to report on
the next thing i want to show is open
telemetry which is going to be the piece
that consumes
those activity events to do something
interesting with them
now the activity api does have a way to
report on that information
um but the api kind of sucks
um kind of sucks a lot actually so when
i call
activity.start um that can raise
an event for that information and that
information
event actually comes through a new api
called a diagnostic listener
so typically what you have is a static
diagnostic
source source equals new
diagnostic listener and then the name of
the diagnostic listener is going to be
the same name as your activity
okay so the activity objects themselves
don't have events i can subscribe to
instead what we have is instead of
starting activity just like this what
we'll do is we'll say
source dot start activity
passing in the activity and we can also
pass in context
i'm not going to pass in anything so
what this will do is start the activity
and raise a diagnostic event
so that something can subscribe to that
and then act on it if they want to
and the way i can subscribe to that
diagnostic event is that there is a
diagnostic listener that all listeners
that's
that is an observable of diagnostic
listener
and i could say subscribe to
this die observer diagnostic listener
which also has events
that give you the start stop and
exceptions
for activities but i don't know
like observables are fun and all but
they're they're kind of a pain to deal
with in your infrastructure code
um so what open telemetry will do
is kind of encapsulate all these
different pieces for you so they don't
have to have these
these observables and subscribers and
just say here just implement this class
tell me the name of the activity that
you want to listen to
and here's a method that i will call
whenever that thing happens
so i've got a
slightly more complex application than
what we just saw
to try to give you a little bit better
illustration about um
in a more complex distributed system how
these different calls get pieced
together
so i have a micro services based
application
and in this micro services based
application i've got a number of
different services and components
running in order to be able to service
individual requests
so in this case it's a it's a website to
be able to view orders and place orders
if you guys are doing microservices then
it's got to be a spa right so we're
going to have an angular ui
the angular ui talks to a composition
gateway or api gateway it's a
bff or back in for front end so that api
is explicitly designed for the one ui
and then that composition gateway will
then
compose multiple api calls from the back
end be able to service up that one call
to the front end
in this case it's just using like a like
a web api call
which you can imagine that could be
graphql or rest
or just web api that's whatever you want
to do to be able to consume to be able
to compose
all these different information from the
back end be able to display in the front
end
now what i'd like to have happen in my
distributed trace is that
if something goes wrong or if i just
want to see some information about
all these different pieces that i can
see just one
kind of graph of calls that has all
these different communications that
happen
but what i'd like to have happen is not
just have
like the http traffic as part of this
picture
in that distributed trace so if my api
call
makes a call to a database well it would
kind of be nice to know like what
happened with that database was it was
it called to the database slow was it
fast did it return too many records or
not enough records
what were the parameters being passed in
that could be valuable information for
me if i'm trying to diagnose an issue
of something going wrong in a test or
production environment
so really what i want to have happen is
every single one of these arrows
show up in my distributed trace
the next one is going to be a lot more
complicated
because this one is dealing with the
rights on the reside it's kind of a
very simple scenario usually it's a fan
out of calls
gathering information and then pulling
it back in again but for
for the cases where i'm changing
information or performing an action or
operation in the system
well this time i could have a lot more
pieces and they could be a lot more
distributed
so in this application i've got a single
angular front end and i click a button
on the page to say place order
well that calls directly the sales api
to say okay i want to place my order
but the sales api knows that it can't
fulfill this order
by itself so it's going to just record
some information
in its database and send a message
to a back-end messaging endpoint to
actually process the order and do its
work
so this back-end messaging endpoint
receives a message
via rabbitmq or azure service bus or
whatever it might be
makes a call to a database and now it
needs to notify
multiple consumers that the sale has
been made and now you need to start
fulfilling the order
so initially the sales made a call to
just send a message to a single endpoint
but at this point
i want to actually notify multiple
consumers so i may use a fanout or pub
sub
kind of message to notify lots of
consumers that this
order is in it's time to go to work be
yourself
so at this point i'm going to publish a
message out to multiple subscribers i've
got
finance subscribing i've got shipping
subscribing and i've got customer
subscribing
and then i'll subscribe to the order
submitted event
now in each one of these they're going
to perform their own
business logic to do their stuff so on
finance side they need to do two things
they have to call into a database
and make a call to a third party payment
gateway
so they'll split those up in two pieces
and say how about let's first call the
call to the database
and send another message to myself which
is to initiate the payment process
and it's doing this because i can't put
both of those in a single transaction i
can't call
stripe and talk to a database at the
same time so split those up into
separate operations
to be independently retried or
failed by themselves so that call makes
out to
another api to some other third-party
payment gateway that we don't own
so in that case i want to see the error
going into the payment gateway
but i don't necessarily have any visual
i don't have any um
i don't have any visibility into what
goes on behind the scenes but i at least
want the api call out to it
now shipping's got some more complex
logic it says well i can ship
my product will never see both events
order submitted
and payment succeeded only when those
two things have happened successfully
can actually shift the order so it's
actually subscribed to two events it's
subscribed to the order submitted of it
and is subscribed to the payment
succeeded event and when both of those
are received
then it finally says okay go ship this
thing via fedex
so another message goes out the door to
our operations folks
to ship the products via fedex or
whatever kangaroo or whatever i don't
know
um and then customers is just uh
recording uh
recording order information for the
customer service site and so if the
customer
calls in for something they've got the
list of orders orders there for the
customer then they go
they can go there and look up more
information and other systems
so that's a ton of arrows but that's
like that pales in comparison with the
typical number of connections i have
with my distributed systems
the ones that i deal with like there's
dozens of messages
in some interactions you know 20 30 api
calls
uh and so i although the graph can get
big
i still want to know like when something
goes wrong or even just like
just i want to look up what happened i
want to be able to see
all these different pieces uh pulled
together
so how do we make this happen well again
five years ago it would have sucked
or even two years ago um i would have
had to like very early on pick
a tracing tool because all of my
infrastructure had to be built towards
that one specific
tracing tool but these days i don't have
to do that i can have my infrastructure
code just go against the generic
activity api
and then have open telemetry as a piece
that's able to
listen for activity events and then pop
them out the door
to our um to whatever exporters we want
so to do this we're going to need some
packages
packages packages the first thing we're
going to need is the hook
for open telemetry into asp.net core
so this is the open telemetry extensions
hosting project and all this
is is the ability to say services dot
add open telemetry
and they build and then from there i can
register uh individual extensions to
open telemetry both on the
instrumentation side
and the exporting side so the next thing
i need to do is actually
instrument my application that comes for
the open telemetry instrumentation
packages
so those packages are listening to
activity events via the
diagnostic listener api uh record
specific interesting events or all of
them and for
those events bashing them up over to our
exporters
so that's the last piece of the puzzle
the exporter libraries
so this point i would choose you know
which which exporter i want
um there are exporters for all of the
all of the major
distributed tracing tools out there
and there's also an exporter for the
open telemetry api
so open telemetry is also defined here's
a standard
web api http api um that
if you just conform to this then i don't
have to change packages
i just change urls so uh
some of the um some of the tracing tools
have started to adopt that standard
and what that would allow me to do is to
really just standardize on open
telemetry and be
agnostic towards any exporters that i'd
be working with now it is still
important that i pull on the individual
instrumentation libraries
my code isn't instrumented by default i
need to opt into this because it is
an operation that can slow the
processing pipeline down like you know
instrumentation is not free
some folks like to do auto
instrumentation via logs i've never
found that works very well
um it doesn't triangulate well and if i
need to add additional information
it's not that great to be able to change
after the fact
and so what the instrumentation
libraries do is
will light on if something is actually
listening to it so i can turn it off in
production and put into lower
environments
or turn it on at a lower rate in
production to ensure they don't degrade
performance
so let's now switch over to my uh
frankenstein's monster
of a demo application and see what we
see
okay now this microservices application
go away i don't need to update now
please no
this microservices application has
everything inside a single solution
because i'm lazy
and it's easier for me to run the whole
thing all at once but in a production
environment
in a real development environment you
don't have everything inside a single
solution
each one of these top-level services
would probably be in their own
repository
maybe in a monorepo but definitely not
in the same individual overall visual
studio solution
so i'm just making my life a little bit
easier so
in each of the applications i've added
the correct
packages for the hosting
the generic hosting library so now i can
say services.blah
i'm adding the appropriate
instrumentation
as well so this is for asp.net core this
is for sql clients
and then for this demo i'm actually
showing two different exporters i'm
showing
jager and zipkin but there are a ton out
there
that you can pull from app insights
jager zipkin prometheus i don't know
other greek gods i think are up there as
well
um that you can pull from and just plug
in the one that you want to
if the open telemetry api is not
supported out of the box so
what i like to do is run through both of
those scenarios um the
get scenario and the post scenario and
see what we see
in our exciting distributed tracing
visualization
now i have put the turbo button on my
laptop so hopefully things go a little
bit faster
building and running all these
applications we'll see
now you may notice some other packages
there i've got um
my library for doing messaging i'm using
in service bus because it's
easier for me to get up and going and
i've also included a package
for in service bus which includes the
instrumentation support for that
so out of the box.net core provides
instrumentation for
asp.net core for http clients for sql
clients and for
azure service bus but i don't always use
azure surface bus sometimes i'm using
rabbitmq
and so i don't have any instrumentation
there so what i've done is added this
package the
extensions diagnostics.open telemetry
that does
two things one is it is able to do the
whole header
to activity to header translation
that asp.net core is doing as well as
surface those
events out to open telemetry
so uh here we should see a
dialogue pop up here in a minute
that is using the
full extent of my design and css
capabilities
so prepare to be wowed yeah there we go
and the first thing i'll do is look at
the list of orders
so behind
uh sales and all the other ones uh
pulling those pieces together
to be able to show on the user interface
and eventually this will come back
yeah it's running like 10 console
windows
which is a lot
but it'll eventually come back with a
list of uh list of orders
um so while that's uh while it's going
what i'll do is i'll switch over to
uh some of the other code to show you um
what else i needed to set up for each of
these
so back in my visual studio
um the other piece of the puzzle i had
to do was in
my program that's cs
for all of these applications i did have
to turn on
the default id format and to force the
default id format to true
now this is a pane.net core 31 but this
is intentional because
net core 30 and 31 were released before
the w3c standard was finalized
and so to ensure that they didn't like
accidentally switch everyone over to a
different
trace id format and like screw
everyone's code up
instead what it is is this make this an
opt-in feature so you have to
explicitly turn on these things for that
net core 31.
now for net core or done at five
those two things will be on by default
or really just the x the activity format
so in dotnet three
five or done at five uh activity
activities will default to the standard
format so it'd be uh good to go there
all right see if our api finally
returned oh lord
aps are running slow today
um okay let's swap over now to our
visualization of this traces
and see what we see there
okay so i've got two windows open
uh one is for zipkin and one is for
jager um now
zipkin is like easy mode for distributed
tracing
um out of the box it doesn't have uh you
can run it without any kind of uh
persistence
storage so you can just have these
traces actually stored in memory
versus being stored in like a database
or something
but it just have plugins for like some
document databases they can store
the traces in kafka as like
streams you can store the traces in
elasticsearch
and a couple others as well for some of
my for my just running locally though
it's just easier to run it based on just
in memory
just to make my life a little bit easier
so
if i search i don't have any traces
coming up yet what i can do is
go back a couple hours to show a let's
go back six hours
to show a previously previous trace that
i ran earlier
in case my slow api never actually comes
up
okay so what is this trace what is a
span
this is the initial get request to
orders to be able to show the list of
orders on the screen
and when i was running earlier it was
pretty that was what almost a second
or 660 milliseconds so that's not not
too
not too great i had to be able to turn
that all that information
uh but we can see is that it's actually
pulling together
the different services in one single uh
one single visualization
so it starts off with that call to the
composition gateway
then the composition gateway is composed
of three different other api calls
so i've got a call to the sales api i've
got a call to the customers api
and i've got a call to the finance api
and then each of those api calls also
makes a call to a database so we can see
as part of the trace the actual calls to
the databases as well
now the other piece of the puzzle here
is well i want to see some information
about each of these
different operations so when i click one
of the operations over here on the right
is some of the additional tags as part
of that individual operation
so this is what um this is what open
telemetry actually adds
on top of the activity information uh
that comes just kind of standard from
data core data core doesn't add any
additional information about what the
request was doing
and so ideally i don't just have like an
api request is made great
i want some context about what that
operation was so that's what all these
different tags are it tells me the host
information the method the path
uh what the status code of if it's good
or not um
yeah and then this is the incoming api
call now i have the second one
which is making the api call uh this is
the receiving one from
the sales side so receive that sales api
call
and i can see the additional information
we have there
and then we can click down into the
actual database call that i made
so over here this is now a database kind
of trace
plugging into sql client to be able to
show
uh sql information so
this information here is the actual
statement being used
inside of that sql call now it has
scrubbed out some of the identifying
information so i won't see parameters
i want more information like that that's
when i start to switch over to a
log tool to see the individual set of
details
for that for that one call
so you can see that it's got all the api
calls
all of the database calls
all in this nice hierarchical view that
plugs everything together so if i
compare this picture with
yeah so it looks like this right i have
the incoming call
that one call that was the top-level
operation okay the second level call and
then three calls to three databases
well that's exactly what we have here in
one single view
let's look at jager because jaeger is a
bit nicer
and i'll go over to the composition
gateway looking back at the last
six hours and find those traces
and then we say oh my god it finally
oh no that was from five hours ago yeah
the first one's like five seconds so
this one might still
be taking a while to uh to return
okay so uh let's look at the fast one
that's more interesting
um so yeah it's a similar kind of view
right we've got the overall
the overall call we have the sub calls
being made
into the different pieces of information
i can see individual tags about
what those look like um jager is a bit
nicer looking you can kind of see that
it's
a bit cleaner looking interface and
its searching capabilities are a bit
nicer as well
so that was the get operation let's see
if my
ui ever returned did not
refresh to see if it ever comes back
i don't think it is that's okay i've got
my old trace
um so in my
more complex example
where i had all these different things
going on
all at once that starts to get now super
super complicated of all these different
pieces
uh getting plugged together so um
this is where it can become a little bit
difficult to to even find
this trace versus something else so
after i show this trace i'll show you
ways of
enhancing the the output inside of those
different traces to be able to have more
contextual information
for your individual trace uh distributed
traces
so let's find this one now so this one
starts off with the angular ui calling
the sales api
so let's go back over to jager because
jager is nicer and go back up to
the sales api
like six hours and find the traces
okay here's one that is for creating an
order
and you notice now that i bump the size
up a little bit
it's got a lot more services it's
talking to so each of these little
bubbles here are the different services
that were associated with this
initial request they were part of this
overall trace
if they click one of those no no this is
this is a lot more complicated
of things going on so let's collapse a
couple of these down to kind of walk
through these steps one by one
so he said the first thing was there's
an api call to say create an order so
that's this first one we have here
um i can see the tags as part of it you
notice it doesn't have like the
the payload is part of it so it's not
including that level of detail
that's intentional this tracing tool
is not meant to replace your logs your
logs are still there to get the details
but the problem with logs is that
uh is a part of cardinality of the data
there's a ton of data in your logs that
how do you find the right data
that's really what the traces are
intended to do so if for example i saw
something
wrong going on with this call then what
i would do
is include a span id which is right over
here
in my logs so if i include the span id
and my logs i could search for that span
id
in my logs and now just have just the
logs for that one operation in my trades
so sales api sent a message
via rabbitmq
that's the send we have right here and i
can see some information about it it's a
producer
there's a payload size there's 34 bytes
and then have a consumer that's going to
receive that information
and now process it and publish the
message out so as part of this we should
expect to see a couple things
talking to a database and publishing a
message
now inside of that i've actually got a
lot more information going on here
so what i've done in the uh this is in
service bus i'm using to
be able to record this information um
i've enriched
the tags on the activity with a lot of
contextual information so that if
i'm someone that's needing to diagnose
something wrong i've got a lot more
information
for me um so what i've actually done
here is
in my configuration
i go just look at one of my endpoints
we will see that after i call add
open telemetry tracing which is the
services dot from the extensions hosting
i have the exporters for zipkin and
jaeger which i just need to tell them
the url to point to then i have a
different instrumentation
and one of the things i've done for demo
purposes is to capture
the actual body of the messages so
probably it's not something you'd want
to do in a production and for my
production environment but for demo
purposes as well as for like
dev like any low environment lower than
production
you can flip that on so that you can
more easily diagnose a bug in a
distributed system
so back in my ui i can see like the full
message body is part of that so
all the other junk that might be part of
this one of these things the submit
order command sure
and then we can see what does it do next
it makes three calls to the database so
i can say one
select the product id and name sure
two other calls of the database and then
finally down here it has a publish the
order submitted event
we saw that there was three subscribers
to that event
the customer service the finance service
and the shipping service
now shipping didn't do anything at first
because it was waiting for that second
event to come in
so as part of its information we just
see yep it
received this message that said this
order has been submitted
but the other ones are more complicated
so customers was doing some database
stuff to insert some information about
the customer
and then that then it was done and the
finance did a couple things
uh first it saved some information into
its database
so it said save
yes save the data to the database or get
give the information out and then save
the data to the database
there we go yeah insert into this and
some stuff
it's done all right and then
it's going to publish a new message that
is hey i have
uh oh no it needs to actually submit the
payment so this one
is going to send a message to itself to
say i need to
charge the customer so this message is
initiate the payment process
and then
down here it's going to make a call the
api
to this other third party api which is
just localhost you get the idea
to make the payments once that payment
is successful then i publish a message
saying
payment has succeeded shipping receives
it
receives a message and says okay now
that shipping is good i'm going to send
a message to the operations to
ship with fedex
here we are and then itops receives it
operations and save some information
that said yes
i'm going to ship this package to the
customer
so that entire complicated graph of all
those different services together
can be represented in one single
distributor trace that we see here
now these tags were done automatically
by
our our uh really just by the underlying
um uh exporters from
open telemetry putting all this
information in there
but if you wanted to add your own
information to that let's say
we have
we have some additional context
information that's relative to
like our sre folks so when they're
trying to diagnose a problem
they can fix it without worrying about
like having to go back to the logs or
something like that
so inside any of my api calls if i start
to have like
some contextual information like this
one for example i say oh i got a
i got a customer id then what i could do
is go to activity
dot current yes
dot current that's the current running
activity so in this case would be the
asp.net core activity
and then i could say add
tag and it could put a tag in here
so it could be like customer.id and i
give it a value of
customer id
so now when we see our
traces show up for this operation it
will include the customer id in my trace
which means inside of jager instead of
just like blindly going around and like
i don't know
then what we can do is actually search
by tag and say cust.id
equals three and now we'll pull up all
the
spans with that customer identifier
the last piece we can do is if i have
additional context information that
really needs to flow to
all of my traces tags are only
associated with the
current operation there's another piece
which is called baggage
now baggage is part of a new emerging
standard
which is designed to attach additional
context information
to all of the communications that get
the initial
trace context identifier so in this case
add baggage will actually flow that
baggage information to
all the child activities and when it
make calls out the door
via http or via rabbitmq or whatever it
might be
then those information is put together
into a single header that then flows out
the door
to be consumed on the other side so this
would mean that that customer id would
show up for
all of the subsequent spans and
operations and activities for
this customer id so that's pretty cool
we use that a lot in my
clients to be able to quickly
triangulate like someone has a problem
okay give me your order id
i can quickly see all of the traces for
for that order across all the actions
that users performed
pretty rad stuff
so that was distributed tracing made
easy with
net core we're looking for net5 the only
thing we need to update is to remove the
move the
the default the the activity id format
from w3c because it's down by default
otherwise it works exactly out of the
box
now the other cool thing is that the
activity api
is not actually tied to net core it
targets.net standard
and so classic asp.net web forms also
has
this tracing stuff built into it as well
so they have actually updated
those to use this standard um as long as
you just
update this out of band system
diagnostics
uh package you'll get the new w3c
tracing supports um out of the box so
really cool stuff
so um we have a couple minutes for
well negative one minute for questions
so i'll just uh answer a couple of those
real quick
if i don't answer them in the next 30
seconds then i will answer them on
the slack channel the first one was
um does the net framework 472 support
open telemetry
um yes it does because the system
diagnostics uh and open telemetry apis
target net standard 2o
so that means it actually supports uh
net472 now depending on the runtime that
may be a little different so classic
asp.net
versus asp.net core you'll have to check
the details in each of those
the other questions were over so i'll
take the rest of the questions and move
them over to our slack
otherwise good have a great
uh it's wednesday uh and i'll have a
great tuesday evening
so thanks everyone